[Music]
okay we got one power girl jumbo combo
gonna lose that hand puddin anything
else for you today boys gotta be her
[Applause]
hey try to work here
Pamela we are out of time finger at last
mother earth salvation
look out beautiful you are it works it
works this is no ordinary leafy mouse
but a harbinger of the new wave IV in
the floor on achmet we're up to
questionable activities we need help
Holly quick reporting for duty sir
god help us
where can I find your BFF poison ivy I
can help to find him but you're gonna
put in a good word for me with the
parole board hmm no really gonna change
us all into plan humankind have had
their chance and you've had yours
[Music]
I thought we were friends friends don't
let friends kill 7 billion
[Music]
[Applause]
you are willing to agree to my terms why
should I help you hasn't seen as you are
you enjoy living how about just a little
something a sweeten the deal Spa Day
autographed picture for my little cousin
he's real sick okay fine whatever you're
the boss
[Music]
and